‏You have many slaves the first
thing you will do is put yolks around
their nech
to chains.
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلم what
is
that
com to manind
and find them in ‏and chains.
That means he comes upon a group of
slaves.
Slaves
that are in darkness.
‏But how can they be slaves
if they are living their lives
based on what they want
that a
be free
righte I don't have to listen anyone
make it up as I go along
that is exactly the slavery that they
were in
follow any particularion
‏here and there
but ultimately they did whatever they
want
even theigion that they aded to theigion
and the following of
they to
the sacred months you know what they
would do they would
affirm the sacred month because they
couldn'tight
‏could
have
would have
those
inalculating
the sacred month andalculating the
months to put it off one year and bring
it on the other.
‏Because sa putamper
on their agenda
they drank whatever they want to drink
they down with who they want to lay down
they said whatever they want they
accepted whatever they want and reed
what they desired
this is the state that they were in
butes
‏as being
a state of slavery
yokes and chains.
‏You know what's very interesting is
that the idea that is perpetuated
and the idea thatan uses to scare the
believer off
of the path of Allah and hinder away
from Allah's path
is that if you believe if you follow
this propenger
you are
‏life
rules
you have this
everything is
so الشيطان
the idea
to the un assuming
that following the prophet محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم
ممد صلى الله عليه وسلم
on the followers of the propet صلى الله
عليه وسلم
حرام
[Silence]
حلال
اللهم
allدم
عليه
‏paraday
now
vast parad
spse
‏if
go
under
[Silence]
حم
‏and
the description of our prop صلى الله
عليه وسلم
and being dred around by
that is
الشيطان
انما يدعو حزبه ليكون
ايش من اصحاب السعير
‏is coners
of people
and so our propon
in yes and in agony scared of everything
but
‏bir goard
right
of a cating
af of
this and that
andev
them of their ande
[Silence]
صحيح البخاري ومسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
هلكت
ماكسد
وقعت على امراتي وانا صائم
‏He said
I I got we while I was fing and
relations with my wife.
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏said youble to 60 consecutive days said
no I could even fast this one day I
could get through it this is what landed
me here
said are you able to feed 60 people said
والذي بعثك
ليس ثم
افقر مني فيما بين الحرتين
‏more
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ابو هريره
صلى
‏was said take
a bas
on the on the st
and feed to
people
المدينه
قال ابو هريره فضحك رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم حتى بدت نواجذه
اطعمه اهلك
[Silence]
لى
المغيره بن شعبه رضي الله عنه
عامس
عمر بن الخطاب
mighty
armies
army waspatched with 40,000
كسره
كسره كسره
منكم رجل
المغيره ابن شعبه سلما شئت
عامل كسر
ما انتم
المغيره بن شعبه
نحن اناس من العرب كنا في شقاء شديد وبلاء
شديد
كنا نم الجلد والنوى من الجوع
ونلبس الشعر والوبر
ونعبد الشجره والحجر
فبينما نحن كذلك
اذ بعث الله الينا رسولا
من انفسنا نعرف اباه وامه
‏as
we
father
and
this
promised us
من قا
فقتل سار الى جنه
لم يرى مثلها قط
وان من عاش منا ملك رقابكم
are
the likes of which we have never
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا
نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يغفر لنا ذنوبنا
وان يكفر عنا خطايانا ان شاء الله تعالى
وف
الشيخ سامح عسل ان شاء الله
خطبه وبارك الله فيكم والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا اللهم
صل على
صت على ابراهيم وعلى
[Arabic recitation]
ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل فلا
هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
وصفيه من خلقه وحبيبه
البشير النذير والسراج المنير ارسله الله
رحمه للعالمين
فانار به العقول وشرح به الصدور وفتح به
اعينا عميا واذانا صما وقلوبا غلفا
فصلى الله وسلم وبارك عليه وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم
من نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها
وخلق منها زوجها وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا
ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون
به والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد
فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله وخير
الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وشر
الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه
ضلاله وكل ضلاله في النار ثم اما بعد
اردو الله
fort
[Silence]
الله
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
سبحانه وتعالى
الله
[Silence]
في
‏will
[Silence]
spe
الله
محمد صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
‏my sister
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتالى اسلام
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
[Silence]
سبحانه وتعالى
امام ابن القيم الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
رحمه الله
المؤمن في سيره الى الله سبحانه وتعالى
اشبه بالطائف
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
عباده
الله سبحانه وتعالى
فتنه
‏need
الله سبحانه وتعالى
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ساد
احب الله لما يغذو
من
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
وان تعدوا نعمه الله لا تحصوها
وما بكم من نعمه فمن الله
سبحانه وتعالى
‏ating
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
سبحانه وتعالى
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ساد
انا اعلمكم بالله واشدكم له خشيه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
الله
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
ليس الخائف الذي يبكي ويمسح عينيه
ولكن الخائف لكن الخائف الذي يترك ما يترك
ما يخاف ان يحاسب عليه ذا وان هو ترولي
فيذا الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
سبحانه وتالى
سوره الفاتحه
الفاتحه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
الله رب العالمين
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
رب
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏the
of affairs
and we all our mind
ourselves
that we are toى
for everything
and our love for
سوره الفاتحه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الرحمن الرحيم
merفful
merful
what is thisinding
us bringing to our minds
brings to
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى ساز
قل يا عبادي الذين اسرفوا على انفسهم
لا تقنطوا من رحمه الله
ان الله يغ غفر الذنوب جميعا
انه هو الغفور الرحيم
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
سوره الفاتحه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
مالك يوم
سوره الفاتحه
mind
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
وترى الناس سكارى
وما هم بسكارى
ولكن عذاب الله شديد
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
عدي بن حاتم الطائي
الله سبحانه وتعالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم ساد
ما منكم من احد
الا وسيكلمه رب ليس بينه وبينه ترجمان
او حجاب يحجبه
ينظر ايمن منه فلا يرى الا ما الا ما قدم
من عمل وينظر اشم منه فلا يرى الا ما قدم
من عمل وينظر تلقاء وجهه
فلا يرى الا النار
فاتقوا النار ولو بشق تمر
صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏and
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى اقول قولي هذا واستغفر
الله لي ولكم
الحمد لله رب العالمين والعاقبه للمتقين
ولا عدوان الا على الظالمين نعوذ بالله من
شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات اعمالنا من يهده
الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله صلى الله عليه
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
ماي دير براذ ان سيسترز
سلف صالح الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
حروري
اللهديق
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
من عبد الله بالخوف وحده فهو حروري
ومن عبد الله
بالرجاء وحده فهو مرجئ ومن عبد الله بالحب
وحده
فهو زنديق
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
ورش الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
كثر ما شئت من الخطايا ما دام القدوم على
الكريم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏some sister
yes
to someone
sister
would
know
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتعالىش
الله سبحانه وتعالى ساز اعلموا ان الله
شديد العقاب
وان الله غفور رحيم
الله
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى الله
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى ساز نبئ عبادي
اني انا الغفور الرحيم وان عذابي هو
العذاب الاليم
محمد
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
حرام
‏for
حريه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
حديث
انس رضي الله تعالى عنه
الله
صلى الله عليه
بن اسرائيل
and was
the devra
from ‏sin
would
he would from committing sin
until time
to him
leave me to my lord
so wor
يغفر فر الله لك
الله ولن يدخلك الجنه والله الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم الله
سبحانه وتعالى
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى
هل انت اعلم بينا
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏skeبحانه
وى
الله سبحانه وتعالى الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏because
our need to
صلى الله عليه وسلم حديث
ان يكون الله
ورسوله احب اليه مما سواهما
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏s
الله سبحانه وتالى الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا واسرافنا في امرنا
وثبت اقدامنا وانصرنا على القوم الكافرين
اللهم حبب الينا الايمان
وزينه في قلوبنا وكره الينا الكفر والفسوق
والعصيان واجعلنا من الراشدين اللهم
اجعلنا لك ذكارين
لك شكارين لك رهابين
عليك مقبلين عن سواك مدبرين اللهم انا
نسالك رضاك والجنه ونعوذ بك من سخطك
والنار اللهم انا نسالك الفردوس الاعلى في
الجنه اللهم اظلنا في ظلك يوم لا ظل الا
ظلك اللهم ادخلنا الجنه بلا حساب ولا
سابقه عذاب اللهم اعزنا ولا تذلنا واكرمنا
ولا تهنا وانصرنا ولا تنصر علينا وامكر
لنا ولا تمكر علينا اللهم من اراد ان يمكر
بنا فامكر به اللهم من ارادنا والاسلام
والمسلمين بخير فوفقه لكل خير ومن ارادنا
والاسلام والمسلمين بسوء فرد كيده في نحره
واجعل تدميره في تدبيره وخذه اخذ عزيز
مقتدر يا رب العالمين وصلى الله وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين واقم الصلاه
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه
قدت
الصلاه
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا الله
استووا استقيموا يرحمكم الله يور لاينز
بليز استووا
استووا
الله اكبر
سبحان اللهك وتبارك اسمك
ولا الهك اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
سبح اسم ربك الاعلى
الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا تنسى
الا ما شاء الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى
ونيسرك لليسرى
فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى
سيذكر من يخشى ويتجنبها
الاشقى
الذي يصلى النار الكبرى
ثم لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا
قد افلح من تزكى
وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون
الحياه الدنيا
والاخره
خير
وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى
صحف ابراهيم
وموسى
الله
[Silence]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
الله اكبر
[Silence]
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
[Arabic recitation]
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
هل اتاك حديث الغاشيه
وجوه
يومئذ خاشعه
عامله
ناصبه
تصلى نارا حاميه
تسقى من عين انيه
ليس لهم طعام الا من ضريع
لا يسمن ولا يغني من جوع
وجوه
يومئذ
ناعمه
لسعيها راضيه في جنه عاليه
لا تسمع فيها لا غي
فيها عين
جاريه فيها سرر مرفوعه
واكواب
موضوعه
ونمارق مصفوفه
وزرابي
مبثوثه
افلا ينظرون
الى الابل كيف خلقت
والى السماء
كيف رفعت والى الجبال كيف نصبت
والى الارض كيف سطحت فذكر انما انت مذكر
لست عليهم
بمسيطر
الا من تولى وكفر فيعذبه الله العذاب
الاكبر ان الينا
ايابهم
ثم ان علينا حسابهم
الله
سبحان
سمع الله لمن حمده
ولك
كثيرا
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر الله استغفر الله
[Silence]
அலா அலைக்கும்
pleas
have cle of இounம
‏first one is be holding a world in h of
as you know he is leing us after 5 years
of serv to this community and the din
আফটারশা ইনশাআল্লাহ।